Speaker 1: So one of the 2022 races that we're
following more and more closely is that of the
Texas gubernatorial race, we believe that Beto
O'Rourke is going to be entering as a Democratic
challenger against the incumbent Republican
governor, Greg Abbott. Greg Abbott has been
an absolute disaster for the state of Texas. He
has been disgusting, along with his lieutenant
governor, Dan Patrick, since day one of the
pandemic, the infamous grandmas willing to die
for the economy incident. Of course, as you might
remember, Greg Abbott has been absolutely horrible
on energy. Texas, of course, with this big boy,
libertarian, independent energy grid, which has
failed them in the winter and it's failed them in
the summer. And it's just a disaster for Texas.
And then now, of course, recently with Texas
seeing covid run rampant during the Delta spike,
this has fortunately really hurt the approval
ratings of Greg Abbott. And we have additional
new data about this. More Texas voters now believe
that Greg Abbott does not deserve reelection. And,
of course, they are completely correct. More Texas
voters believe Greg Abbott does not deserve to be
reelected, according to a poll released yesterday
Tuesday. The survey was conducted by Quinnipiac
University, finds that 51 percent of registered
voters in Texas believe Abbott doesn't deserve
reelection, compared with 42 percent who
say he does deserve a third term. These are
disastrous numbers for an incumbent
Republican Texas governor, and I love it.
The opposition to Abbott's reelection is up from
June. A different Quinnipiac poll in June found
46 percent said reelect and 48 percent said
no. Now it's only 42 percent say reelect,
51 percent say no. Basically like a four point
slide in the direction of bad, I should say,
from the standpoint of negative. The most recent
poll also found only for 44 percent of Texans
approve of the way Abbott is handling his job as
governor, 47 percent now disapprove. This is the
first time since Quinnipiac started polling Texas
that Abbott's approval rating is below disapproval
referred to as being under water. This
is absolutely fantastic. Now, most
Republicans still support Abbott, 83 percent of
Republicans approve. Only 12 percent disapprove.
As far as independents go, 43 percent approve.
Only six percent of Democrats approve in Texas.
Now, just as an example of how absolutely horrible
this guy is, this was over the weekend on FOX
News. Chris Wallace really grilling Greg Abbott
over his claim that, listen, we don't have to
worry about the abortion law, the dystopian
abortion law that we passed, restricting the
ability of women who have been raped from
obtaining abortions. We don't have to worry about
that because we're going to eliminate rapists,
bend the virus. Right? I mean, just make murder
illegal, solve the problem. OK, let's listen.
Speaker 3: Is it reasonable to say to
somebody who was the victim of rape and
might not understand that they are pregnant,
you know, until six weeks? Well, don't worry
about it, because we're going to eliminate
rape as a problem and attack.
Speaker 1: It doesn't make sense. No,
but let's see what he says as well.
Speaker 3: There's multiple things I
have to say in answer to this for the first thing,
obviously, is that survivors of sexual assault,
they deserve support, care and compassion.
Speaker 1: Now, it's funny how he says obviously
much of the Republican Party
doesn't make it obvious, actually.
Speaker 3: And Texas is stepping up
to make sure that we provide that by
signing a law and creating in the governor's
office a sexual assault survivors, Cecil, as
force. But separately from that, Chris, I got to
point out about the ways that I have fought to go
to arrest and apprehend and try to eliminate
rape, but I sought the death penalty. But the
governor excuse me, because we are running out of
time. There were more than fifteen thousand rapes
in twenty nineteen when you were governor.
Speaker 1: Yeah, apparently just, you know,
ending rape by threatening people with
really strict punishments. You know,
he he wanted the death penalty for rapists. We
really continue to lack evidence that the death
penalty is really a deterrent. We've studied
that for a very, very long time. But, you know,
we're going to eliminate rape is kind of like ban
coronavirus and just be done with it. It doesn't
make any sense. And then, of course, meanwhile,
the latest is Texas has this disaster with covid.
Texas has this disaster with energy and.
What is Abbott doing? Abbott is launching
voter fraud audits from the 2020 election.
Bowing to Trump's pressure, Vanity Fair reporting
Greg Abbott is suddenly bending over backwards
to find twenty election fraud. Abbott's office
says it has been reviewing votes in
certain Texas counties for months,
but others say the mad dash only started after
Donald Trump demanded an audit. Greg Abbott is
going to be pushing for auditing multiple county
auditing, recounting who even knows what these
things mean at this point in time. Four counties
in Texas, Trump won Texas. There is no point. We
talked about this on the bonus show yesterday.
There is no point to do this whatsoever.
Texas is so poorly served. Greg Abbott, Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick, remember the Cancun Cruz
fiasco? It would bring me no greater pleasure
than to see Greg Abbott just absolutely crushed
in twenty twenty two. And Beto O'Rourke could
be the guy to do it. I don't know. I mean,
coming off of a loss is never doesn't put you
in a particularly strong position. Last week,
one of our live callers asked, is Betto really
the right guy to face off against Abbott,
given that he lost his last race? I don't know
the answer to that. But we have time. Listen,
Matthew McConaughey, Matthew McConaughey, death,
depending on your preference, better O'Rourke,
Beto O'Rourke, whatever pronunciations
you have for these folks, they would all
be better than Greg Abbott for sure. And we're
going to follow this race very, very closely